got Tasha in Fayetteville North Carolina
Tasha how are you I'm doing getting
yourself
oh I'm focusing not finish young lady
how can I help you talking about the
student loans earlier and I have two
children that are well they're young
adults that are entering college in the
fall one have already completed at
school one year and so we pick out a
Parent PLUS loan he chose the private
school and I previously had taken out a
Parent PLUS loan for my daughter to also
finish because he had maximized her
loans and so we had to take out the
Parent PLUS loan so that's all ready to
plant PLUS loan so we already taken out
and now my other son is getting ready to
answer so we're looking in both of them
chose private schools to start in the
fall and both on my private school which
we would have to pick out Parent PLUS
loans they scan for exam so I didn't
save up for them for college when they
were younger and also when they
graduated we didn't do much with
scholarships and things like that so we
didn't take advantage of that so I think
that's why I went on and did the Parent
PLUS loan but then my husband's trying
to get out of debt now but with these
Parent PLUS loans they're causing us to
do more in debt mm-hmm yeah it is and
you know what I appreciate you hitting
the nail on the head Tasha because a lot
of parents end up feeling that guilt and
they end up rationalizing taken out
these Parent PLUS loans and because you
think you're doing your kids a favor so
looking at this before we even dig in on
that how much is this private school
what's it cost per year okay all right
so it's 40 around 40,000 for both of
them so tell me this I'm gonna shift
real quick and there's a reason about
40,000 okay so how much in Parent PLUS
loans have you all taken out thus far
taken out
17 and 22 so it was like already 39,000
already okay all right now let's pause
here and let's go to you and your
husband situation
how long have you all been married six
years and what's your household income
okay and what kind of debt do you all
have break it down for me okay
for him he doesn't have much debt he is
only like about 20,000 but for me I did
have I went to a private school too but
that's what I'm trying to tell my
children hey you know go to something
wait for the ball where you can go you
guys yeah no one told me how much do you
have student loan debt how much student
loan debt do you have that we have I
have one hundred and sixty-seven
thousand four hundred and eleven dollars
okay I'm sorry I blacked out a little
bit while you were talking right there
tell me that number again 167,000 that's
what I thought you told me okay all
right so that's student loan for you you
said your husband's got twenty thousand
what is the twenty thousand on a vehicle
what is it is there what else does that
it okay keep going you got a credit card
debt everything's like three hundred and
seventeen thousand six hundred and
twenty-five dollars okay yeah okay how
much is credit card debt credit card
debt is probably about thirty thousand
okay all right so looking at this Tasha
you have a hundred and sixty-seven
thousand four hundred and eleven reasons
why your kids need to wake up and look
at this scenario do you follow me
see you you've walked through this
you've lived this you have this souvenir
of student loan debt that's hanging
that's that's driving you insane let's
break that cycle
okay the school that they're going to it
and gonna save the day it's the quality
of who they are and what they're
standing for and what they're going
about so we I want you to help in this
like whatever you've signed on for
you've signed on for it for this for
this upcoming semester because I know
the ink is dry and the paperwork is done
but here's the deal
they're gonna have to get focused on
looking for scholarships and grants if
they want to be there this is not this
is not something that we want to pay it
forward and and I say this with that
kind of attitude because so many people
believe the school you go to is gonna
save the day and it's not if anything
what its gonna do is cause delay and
right it delays people to be able to
follow through on the baby steps and to
get intentional and so again young
people I don't expect them to know but
parents I want you to be able to be real
with them and again with what you have
going on no because all your kids are
going to do is continue down this path
and got to continue now you and your
husband you all got an appetite for debt
and we're gonna have to kind of kick
that to the curb right and we got to be
clear and I also want to encourage you
and challenge you on be careful with
your pronouns Tasha you said he's only
got twenty thousand and that you have no
no you got a pronoun problem we write
speak French we you all you said I do it
means we do it means you guys are
dealing with this together and I tell
you what I'm gonna do I'm gonna push you
a free gift for your way and I'm gonna
send you the Financial Peace University
and I want you and your husband to go
together because yes you've got a big
chunk of student loan debt one hundred
six to seven thousand but they can get
fixed but only if you fix it there's not
a government program there's not
anything out there that's gonna save the
day and I want you to hear this because
when we decide to stand up for ourselves
we got our own cake ball in America and
we begin to realize that hey we can take
charge of this and it ain't gonna be
easy you never said that but it will be
worthwhile so Tasha we're gonna send you
a Financial Peace University I want you
and your husband to get in there but I
want you to have a conversation with
your young people ASAP
so they can wake up and look at this and
have a different opportunity moving
forward half the conversation you wish
someone would have had with you